Hey guys, you know what I do when I'm done drinking a plastic bottle of water? I do the environmentally correct thing to do. I smash it. I cap it. I pull it in the blue bin. I smash it. I cap it. I put it in the blue bin.
嘿，伙计们，你们知道我喝完一瓶塑料瓶装水后会做什么吗？我会做环保正确的事。我把它捏扁，盖上盖子，扔进蓝色回收箱里。我把它捏扁，盖上盖子，扔进蓝色回收箱里。
Everybody. I smash it. I cap it. I put it in the blue bin. Smash it. Yeah. Ew. Smash it, cap it.
大家。我把它捏扁，盖上盖子，扔进蓝色回收箱里。捏扁它。耶。呃。捏扁它，盖上盖子。
Look at your little, Jay, look at a little flare you got going. You lit that thing, I mean. That's what we get for doing this at four. No, it's nice, though. It's giving it a nice kind of vibe. You like the kick? All right. You got a little California vibe.
看看你那点小火苗，杰伊，看看你那点小火光。你把那东西点着了，我是说。这就是我们在四点钟做这个节目的代价。不，不过这挺好的。它营造出了一种很棒的氛围。你喜欢这种感觉吗？好吧。你有一种加州风情。
It's real, it's real. It's real, it's real, it's a little bit too much. How do you feel about the afternoon record? I'm not a fan. Yeah. I'm done with the day a couple hours ago. Yeah. That's what, 765, 5, 4, 3, that's 2 o'clock?
这是真的，这是真的。这是真的，这是真的，有点太过了。你觉得下午录音怎么样？我不喜欢。是啊。我几个小时前就结束一天的工作了。是啊。那是几点，765，5，4，3，那是两点钟吗？
We got you for the whole day, right? I'm just going to quote you. It is a full, it is a work day today, for sure. Yeah, yeah, I will admit. I'll get there. I'll get it up. I'll get it up. Now, but, Shawnee, you're even worse off.
我们得让你录一整天，对吧？我只是引用你的话。今天确实是完整的一天，绝对是工作日。是啊，是啊，我承认。我会做到的。我会把它搞定。我会把它搞定。现在，但是，肖尼，你的情况更糟。
You're in New York, so you're, this is, this is, you're well past dinner time. It's seven there. I know, at 7 o'clock. I have just been going. You must be two and a half hours past dinner time, right? Yeah. No, I ate when I came home. Did you rehearse today?
你在纽约，所以你，这已经是，这已经是，你早就过了晚饭时间了。那里是七点。我知道，七点钟。我一直在忙。你肯定已经过了晚饭时间两个半小时了，对吧？是啊。不，我回家时吃过了。你今天排练了吗？
I did for five hours. Boy. How to go. It's tough. I mean, it's like, you know when you have to concentrate so hard and so specific for so long? Yeah. I don't know. Like on... It's a different kind of tired.
我排练了五个小时。天哪。怎么样。很难。我是说，你知道当你必须如此专注、如此具体地做一件事这么久的时候吗？是啊。我不知道。就像在……这是一种不同类型的疲惫。
It is. It's brain tired. Yeah, you can't take a moment off, right? Because listener, he's talking about, he's doing a one-man show. Gosh, here we go. What's the show called, Johnny? It's called the unknown, but we don't have to, yeah. It's called the unknown.
确实。这是大脑疲惫。是啊，你一刻也不能放松，对吧？因为听众朋友们，他正在谈论的是，他正在排练一部独角戏。天哪，开始了。这出戏叫什么名字，强尼？它叫《未知》，但我们不必，是啊。它叫《未知》。
We don't know. We don't know. How is it going to be? It's a no. It's kind of right there. It's right for, you know. Shoney, what's the name of the theater, too? So we can just get it in there.
我们不知道。我们不知道。会怎么样呢？这是一个“不”。它就在那儿。它就在，你知道的。肖尼，剧院的名字也说一下吧？这样我们就能把它加进去。
It's called the Studio C-view, and it opens January 31st for previews. Studio C-view, January 31st. Gang, get down there. You know, the whole, like, previews and opening. We talked about that before. It's like, if you're selling tickets that people are coming,
它叫Studio C-view，1月31日开始预演。Studio C-view，1月31日。伙计们，去看看吧。你知道，整个，比如，预演和首演。我们之前谈过这个。就像，如果你在卖票，人们就会来，
why do we do the previews in the moment? Just, it opens January 31st. That's what I say. Yeah, I agree. Like, you know, people are selling tickets. You do sell tickets to previews, right? Preview. Yeah, what's that thing with the previews? What do you think it is? It's, you know, it's to work out the kinks before it's officially open, but it's like, well, then don't sell tickets, but we are.
为什么我们要在那个时候进行预演？就说1月31日开演。我是这么说的。是啊，我同意。就像，你知道，人们在卖票。你们确实卖预演的票，对吧？预演。是啊，预演是怎么回事？你觉得那是什么？它是，你知道的，是为了在正式开演前解决掉那些小问题，但就像，好吧，那就别卖票啊，但我们确实在卖。
Then just do rehearsal, call it rehearsal and don't have audio. Yeah, we're rehearsing for two weeks before we, you know. Like, you get a couple weeks of Mulligan, like, don't you dare write a review about this because we don't really mean it yet. It'd be like shooting a bunch of scenes and then you release a rough cut and go, it's just the rough cut, but it's going to theaters. That's right. And that, but Jason, that's when the, that's when the critics come are during previews. Yeah, so it's like what? I don't understand. It's all backwards.
那就直接排练，叫它排练，别弄音响。是啊，我们在开始前排练了两周，你知道的。就像，你有几周的“重来”机会，比如，你敢写关于这个的评论，因为我们还没准备好。这就像拍了一堆场景，然后你发布了一个粗剪版，说，这只是粗剪版，但它要上映了。没错。而且，但是杰森，那是评论家在预演期间来的时候。是啊，所以这是什么？我不明白。这完全是倒退的。
That's how they get the reviews out on opening night. While we're working through our shit, that's when they review the show? Like, I don't know. It doesn't make sense. Why don't you charge half price for previews? I'll mention that to the previous. Hey, Sean, can I ask you a question? Yeah.
这就是他们如何在首演之夜发布评论的方式。当我们还在处理我们的烂摊子时，他们就在评论这部剧？就像，我不知道。这说不通。为什么预演不收半价？我会向预演方提一下。嘿，肖恩，我能问你个问题吗？可以。
Do you have the balls to change the system? Believe me. Let's write a play called Change, and it's about changing the theater system. Charging half price for previews. Yeah. Three full acts. And let's do four months of previews. views in one week.
你有胆量改变这个制度吗？相信我。让我们写一部叫《改变》的剧，内容就是关于改变剧院制度的。预演收半价。是啊。三幕全剧。让我们预演四个月。一周内看完。
Oh my God, that'd be hilarious. Now, Sean, you're finding your brain's working okay as far as remembering all these lines? Well, you know, that's the scariest part. I have found that I've been told in this rehearsal process that some people have ear, what is it called? Yeah, earwigs. And then. Oh, yeah, we had a, we did a, we had a record the other day.
天哪，那太搞笑了。现在，肖恩，你觉得你的大脑在记住所有这些台词方面还行吗？嗯，你知道，那是最可怕的部分。我发现在这个排练过程中，有人告诉我有些人有耳朵，那叫什么来着？是啊，耳麦。然后。哦，对，我们有一个，我们做了一个，我们前几天录了一次。
Oh, that's right. Now, I wonder, I couldn't understand, was he, was he implying that the earwigs, is is reading him his lines all the time or just when he goes up, someone will wisdom. He said for backup, but I know somebody who did an entire run on Broadway with a year record.
哦，对了。现在，我很好奇，他是在暗示耳麦一直在给他读台词，还是只有在他忘词的时候，有人会提醒他？他说那是为了备份，但我认识一个人在百老汇演了整整一轮，戴着耳麦。
There's a few people, yeah. Anyway, so I also talk about change. What are you going to do? What's going to be your safety net? I'm just going to wing it. I don't know. No, you're not. I get sick thinking about it.
有几个人，是啊。总之，我也谈谈改变。你要做什么？你的安全网是什么？我打算临场发挥。我不知道。不，你不会的。一想到这个我就恶心。
Here's what it is, J.B. He's been working on it for months. He's been working on it for months, literally eight hours a day. Yeah, for like three months. He is so diligent about that. You know, Shawnee, he's diligent of nothing else. No, you are. This is the part that I don't get, though, Sean,
事情是这样的，J.B.。他已经为此工作了几个月。他已经为此工作了几个月，真的是每天八小时。是啊，大概三个月了。他在这方面非常勤奋。你知道，肖尼，他除了这个什么都不勤奋。不，你很勤奋。这是我不明白的部分，肖恩，
because you're so beautifully relaxed about your days, your weeks, your years, your months. You know, you don't, you're fine, you're fine relaxing. And you tend to say, hang on, you tend to say no to a lot of things, okay, even more than me. Yeah. Yet you say yes to not only a one-man show, but another play on the back end of,
因为你对你的日子、你的周、你的年、你的月过得非常放松。你知道，你不会，你很好，你很享受放松。而且你倾向于说，等等，你倾向于对很多事情说不，好吧，甚至比我还多。是啊。然而你不仅答应了一部独角戏，还在上一部戏之后又接了另一部戏，你说过你再也不会演戏了。是啊，你还记得他在伦敦的时候吗？记得他在伦敦吗？他说我再也不干这个了。我在干什么？我记得和你谈过，你说为什么我要做这个？我太累了。
of the last thing and you said you would never do another place. Yeah, do you remember when he was in London? Remember he was in London? And he was like, I'm not doing this again. What am I doing? I remember talking to you were like, why am I doing this? I'm so tired.
我不会再做了。我们在通电话。你在伦敦。然后一个月后，你说我要去纽约做这个独角戏。我要做些更难的事情。嗯，因为如果你读了剧本，你会觉得，如果你不演这个，你就是个白痴。
I'm not going to do this. We were on the phone. You were in London. And then a month later, you're like, I'm going to go to New York and do this one minute. I'm going to do something harder. Well, because if you read the script, you'd be like, well, you're an idiot if you don't do this.
因为从来没有过这样的东西。我是说，这是我读过的最不可思议的东西。我是说，太不可思议了。哦，好吧。好吧，很好。他受到了启发。他被剧本内容启发了。那很好。
Because there's never been anything like it. I mean, it's the most incredible thing I've ever read. I mean, it's incredible. Oh, all right. All right, well, good. He's inspired. He's inspired by the material. That's good.
但是，你知道，然后……你还能受到启发，这很好。是啊，有一点。但我谈论的是改变制度。舞台是唯一……就像，剧院是唯一没有替身的地方。所以电视和电影，演员有替身，为什么他们要打光，这样他们就可以去排练或者做别的？
But, you know, then... That's nice that you're still inspired. Yeah, a little bit. But I talk about changes the system. On stage is the only... Like, theater's the only place you don't have a stand-in. So TV and film, actors have stand-ins, why they light the scenes so they can go rehearse or whatever?
但在剧院，我就想，为什么技术周期间不能有替身？为什么我必须在那里站14个小时，等你们给演出打光。我累了。总之，继续吧。你不喜欢找准位置、设置灯光之类的。但也许那个过程有助于巩固它。我相信这就是它的目的。
But theater, I was like, why don't you have a stand-in during Tech Week? Why don't have to stand there for 14 hours while you light the show. I'm tired. Anyway, moving on. You don't like hitting your marks and setting the lights and all that. But maybe that process will help cement it. That's what it's there for, I'm sure.
是啊，是啊，是啊。伙计们，我今天的嘉宾是那种天生就很酷的人，对吧？就像戴着墨镜出生一样。她十几岁时就在非法的仓库派对上表演，她的父母也跟着她一起去。不是把她放下就走，而是像进去了一样。她是英国人。她的艺名来自一个旧的在线屏幕名称。它基本上意味着“吻我”。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Guys, my guest today is one of those people who was just kind of born cool, right? Like came out of the womb in dark sunglasses. She was performing at illegal warehouse parties as a teenager, and her parents came with her. Not dropped her off, but like went inside. She's British. Her stage name came from an old online scream name. It basically meant Kiss Me.
她有联觉，所以音乐在她脑海里是有颜色的。我想和她谈谈这个。她曾是过去十年中一些最大的流行金曲的幕后推手，但在2024年夏天，她经历了一个巨大的时刻，它跳出了音乐圈，进入了美国总统大选。她才华横溢，美丽动人，毫不掩饰地做自己，但大多数人只用一个词来称呼她，brat，她就是了不起的。
She has synesthesia, so music is in colors in her head. I want to talk to her about that. and she's been behind some of the biggest pop hits of the last decade, but in the summer of 2024, she had a moment so big, it jumped out of music and into the American presidential election. She's wildly talented, beautiful, unapologetically yourself, but most people know her as one word, brat, it's the amazing.
Charlie XX。你好？哦！你好。看她来了。嗨，大家好。你好吗？我很好，谢谢。
Charlie XX. Hello? Oh! Hello. Look at her go. Hi, everybody. How are you? I'm good, thank you.
你呢？很好。你在某个厨房里吗？听起来像是，不是吗？不，我在这个。我不知道这是什么。这是一个房间。这是一个医疗场所。
How are you? Good. Are you in a kitchen somewhere? It sort of sounds like it, doesn't it? No, I'm in this. I don't know what this is. It's a room. It's a medical place.
我身后这个。基本上，这就是全部情况。里面有尸体吗？听着，她身后有一堵金属墙。是啊。闪亮的金属。是啊，我怎么这么……谢谢你能来。
This behind me. Basically, that's all that's going on. Are there cadavers in there? Listen, there's a metal wall behind her. Yeah. Shiny metal. Yeah, how I'm so... Thanks for being here.
这太酷了。谢谢你们邀请我。你在哪？你刚才是在拍什么东西吗？是的，抱歉。我迟到了。哦，没事。是啊。
This is so cool. Thank you for having me. Where are you? Were you just filming something or something? Yes, I'm sorry. I was late. Oh, good. Yeah.
你在伦敦吗？不，我在洛杉矶。我现在在洛杉矶。哦，好。你喜欢吗？你喜欢你正在拍摄的东西吗？嗯，是啊，我是说，这只是，我正在为一部电影做宣传，所以我是，这是我第一次为电影做宣传。这是伪纪录片还是另一部？
Are you in London? No, I'm in L.A. I'm in L.A. right now. Oh, good. Are you liking? Are you liking what you? you're filming. Well, yeah, I mean, it's just, I'm doing promo for a movie, so I'm kind of, this is my first time doing promo for a film. Is this the mockumentary or is this the other one?
是的，是伪纪录片。这部电影看起来棒极了。给我们介绍一下吧。它叫什么名字？是啊，它叫《时刻》，基本上是一个，它有点像是2024年的修正主义历史。A24正在制作，或者制作它。是啊，A24正在制作它。它基本上是一个，是啊，它就像一部关于我第一次体育馆巡演的讽刺伪纪录片。没错。而且是啊，它就像一部音乐产业讽刺片，非常类似于
Yes, it's the mockumentary. This movie looks awesome. Tell us about it. What's it called? Yeah, it's called The Moment and it's basically a, it's kind of a revisionist history of 2024. And A24 is producing, or producing it. Yeah, A24 are producing it. And it's basically a, yeah, it's like a satirical mockumentary about my first arena tour. Right. And yeah, it's like a music industry satire very much in the realm of
《摇滚万万岁》和《首演之夜》那种风格。没错。看起来很搞笑。所以你是在扮演一个版本的你自己？是的，没错，没错。一个版本的我自己。你觉得怎么样？是吗？因为那需要即兴表演。即兴表演。有点像做一些，比如，你必须让自己看起来很愚蠢吗？
this is spinal tap and kind of opening night. Right. It looks hilarious. So you're sort of playing like a version of yourself? Yes, correct, correct. A version of myself. How are you liking that? Is it? Because that that necessitates improv. Improv. sort of doing some, like, are you, do you have to make yourself look foolish?
你必须让自己看起来和你真实的样子不同吗？比如，这一切是怎么运作的？嗯，我是说，我的角色是个十足的婊子，每个人都已经认为我是了，所以这完全没问题。谁说的？去谷歌一下。网上都有，宝贝。真的吗？
Do you have to make yourself look different than what you truly are at times? Like, how does all that work? Well, I mean, my character is a real bitch and everybody already thinks that I am one, so that's totally fine. Who said that? Google it. It's out there, babes. Is it really?
是啊，是啊。不，不。不，但，不，它是，它是，是啊。是啊，这是一个非常，这是一个非常棒的过程，我们真的很幸运能和一些，比如，他妈的超棒的演员合作。比如亚历山大·斯卡斯加德在电影里绝对是不可思议的。有剧本吗，还是完全即兴的？不，是有剧本的，但我们确实做了很多即兴发挥。
Yeah, yeah. No, no. No, but, no, it's, it's, yeah. Yeah, it was like a really, it was kind of an amazing process, and we were really lucky to work with some, like, fucking an awesome cast. Like, Alexander Scar's God is just absolutely incredible in the film. Was any of it scripted, or is it really all-imposed? No, it was scripted, but we really did go off on a lot of improv.
我是说，我们电影里也有一些非常了不起的喜剧演员，比如凯特·巴兰和杰米·德米特里，他们简直，我是说，这就像他们的看家本领。他们太，对他们来说太轻松了。是你的主意还是谁的主意？这个主意，是基于我的一个想法，是啊。我想我之前被邀请去做一个更传统的巡演电影，我们要拍摄我的一场演出。我更感兴趣的是颠覆这种形式，
I mean, we had some really incredible comedians in the film as well, like Kate Balan and Jamie Demetriou, who are just, I mean, it's like their bread and butter. They're so, it's so effortless for them. And your idea or whose idea was it? The idea, it was based on an idea by me, yeah. I guess I'd been approached to do a more traditional tour film where we were going to like film one of my shows. And I was kind of more interested in like subverting the form
把那种传统的媒介变成一种感觉更具颠覆性的东西。而且更符合我通常做的工作。这太聪明了。就像你没有把它看得太严肃，而且它有点像你说的《摇滚万万岁》，对吧？是啊，是啊。而且我绝对不是故事里的英雄，
and like taking that kind of traditional medium and then like flipping it into something that felt just a bit more subversive. and kind of more aligned with the work that I generally do. That's super smart. Like you're not taking it too seriously, and it's kind of like Spinal Tap you were saying, right? Yeah, yeah. And I'm definitely not the hero of the story,
这非常符合我在音乐产业的时光，我想。我是说，你们一定要看预告片。谁导演的？艾丹·泽梅里导演了这部电影。这是他的处女作。是啊，那很酷。他真的很了不起，过去拍过很多音乐录影带。
which is very accurate to sort of my time in the music industry, I think. I mean, you guys have to watch the trailer. Who directed it? Aidan Zemeri directed the film. It's his debut feature. Yeah, that's cool. He's really incredible. and has done a lot of music videos in the past.
你觉得整个拍摄过程怎么样？我是说，因为那可能是很长的日子，对吧？是啊，我是说，这部电影的时间表非常紧凑。我是说，我们在一周内写出了初稿，然后在那之后，我们在新年前夜有了初稿，然后我们在三月份就开始拍摄了，所以非常，比如，快，非常，非常快，拍摄本身也是，你知道，大概五周时间，真的就像硬碰硬。
How did you like the whole filming process? I mean, is that, because it can be long days, right? Yeah, I mean, this film was really on kind of like an expedited timeline. I mean, we wrote the first draft in a week, and then after that, we had it in the first draft sort of New Year's Eve, and then we were shooting by March, so it was very, like, fast, very, very fast, as was the shoot itself, you know, sort of like five weeks and kind of like really like hardcore hitting it.
你已经有了，是在你的巡演期间完成的，还是你不得不搭建一个完整的舞台并做所有那些事情？是啊，是啊，我们搭建了一个完整的舞台，而且这个舞台非常，不是我巡演时会做的那种。所以这不是你巡演的真实镜头？不，没有巡演。里面根本没有巡演镜头。那观众呢？你只是找了大批观众来吗？
And did you already have, was it done during one of your tours, or did you have to like get a whole stage together and do all that stuff too? Yeah, yeah, we made a whole stage and the stage is very kind of like not what I would actually do on tour. So it's not real footage from your tour? No, there's no tour. There's no tour footage in it at all. So what about the crowds? You got just big crowds to come in?
我们拍摄了。我们拍摄了，嗯，我不知道，你知道，电影魔术，伙计们。好的，好吧，是啊。因为如果必须在那么多人面前做所有那些事情，而且，比如，等待和向你扔东西，那会很扫兴。是啊，看在上帝的份上，喝口茶吧。喝口那茶。
We filmed. We filmed, well, I don't, you know, movie magic, guys. Good, okay, yeah. Because that would be a bummer to have to do all that stuff in front of all those people and, like, waiting and throwing stuff at you. Yeah, for God's sake, take a sip of your tea. Take a sip of that tea.
其实它真的很烫，这就是情况。我只是在吹它。你有时间。所以你是。所以，对，看。你很小的时候就选了你的名字。我知道你可能，我从来没听过这个答案，但拜托，比如，为了我和我们的听众，
It's really hot, actually, is what's going on. I'm just kind of blowing on it. You got time. So are you. So, right, so look it. You picked your name when you were really young. I know you probably, I've never heard this answer, but please, like, for me and our listener,
告诉我，比如，你是怎么想出这个名字的？哦，也为了我。我是个老头子。帮帮我。嗯，是啊，那是我的MSN屏幕名称。那真的很好。是啊，我就那样用了。我坚持用了那个。
tell me, like, how did you come up with the name? Oh, and for me, too. I'm an old man. Help me. Well, yeah, it was my MSN screen name. That's really good. Yeah, I just kind of went with that. I stuck with that.
它只是一个吻的东西，像Cates。A CASE，Charlie Kiss。是啊，我想当我小得多的时候，我真的觉得它太无聊了，所以我试图让它代表一个更像X级的版本。但它没流行起来，因为它不是事实。伙计，还有人叫你夏洛特吗？
And it's just a kiss thing, like Cates. A CASE, Charlie Kiss. Yeah, I think when I was a lot younger, I was sort of really kind of insecure about it being too. boring, so I sort of tried to make it stand for a much more like X-rated version. But it didn't stick because it wasn't the truth. And dude says anybody call you Charlotte anymore?
不，真的没人叫了。连家人都不叫？不，大家都叫我查理，是啊。查克呢？叫过查克吗？你知道，其实很多美国朋友确实叫我查克。我会的。我喜欢。
No, no one does, actually. Not even family? No, everyone calls me Charlie, yeah. How about Chuck? Ever Chuck? You know, actually a lot of my American friends do say Chuck. I would. I love it.
任何我认识叫查尔斯或查理的人，我总是叫查克。我不知道为什么。我叫查克，还有查克尔斯。是啊。非常好。你记得吗？你当然记得。
Anybody I know that's Charles or Charlie, I always go to Chuck. I don't know what. I get Chuck and I get chuckles. Yeah. Yeah. Very good. Do you remember? Of course you do.
这是我的克里斯·法利版本。你记得你发推特说卡玛拉是Brat的那天吗？是啊。我是说，杰伊，你记得吗？是你发起的吗？是啊，然后卡玛拉的整个竞选活动都变成了你专辑的颜色。那是从你开始的，查理？是啊。
This is my Chris Farley version. Do you remember that day you tweeted Kamala as Brat? Yeah. I mean, Jay, do you remember that? Did you start that? Yeah, and then Kamala's whole campaign became the color of your album. That started with you, Charlie? Yeah.
得了吧。是啊。所以你没发起那个。是专辑的名字叫Brat。哦，好吧。看，我太老了。我女儿会杀了我。没关系。
Come on. Yeah. So you didn't start that. It was the name of the album is Brat. Oh, okay. See, I'm very old. My daughter's going to kill me. It's fine.
那只是一个文化现象。顺便说一句，我是你的大粉丝。这个老古董不懂过去，你知道。别担心。我还需要看《黑道家族》。等等，所以你没有想出Brat这个词。我假设Brat是一个词，是一个短语。我想她做到了。
It was only a cultural phenomenon. By the way, I'm a big fan. This old timer doesn't get past, you know. Don't worry. I still need to watch Sopranos. So wait, you did not come up with the term Brad. I'm assuming Brat was a term, was a phrase. I think she did.
是你发起的吗？是啊，这是我专辑的名字，是啊。但你把它带入了主流，比如在……所以我的专辑是一张封面是绿色的专辑，上面写着brat这个词。那是被互联网上的很多人采用的东西，最终在我也发了那条推特后被卡玛拉采用了。
Did you start? Yeah, it's the name of my album, yeah. But you got it into the main, like in the... So my album was an album where the cover is green. with the word brat on it. And that was something that was sort of like adopted by a lot of people on the internet, eventually by Kamala after I did that tweet.
没错，没错。然后它就变成了对话的一部分，是brat还是不是brat。不，那部分我肯定，我肯定醒着。我是说，谁知道呢？我不知道。听起来你没醒着做多少事，伙计。它在我的洞里找到了我。
Right, right. And then it became sort of part of like the conversation to be brat or not to be brat. No, that part I definitely, I woke up for for sure. I mean, who knows? I don't know. It doesn't sound like you're up for a lot, mate. It found me in my hole.
但是，但是，嗯，不，等等，有更好的说法。但是当你最初把这个标题放在你的专辑上时，它已经是一个词汇表里的短语了吗？不。是啊，是你创造了它。我是说，brat这个词存在，但它不是一个，它是。经典意义上，是的。是的，但没有，我不认为，至少它不在词汇表里，以那种方式，
But, but, um, no, wait, there's a better way to say that. But when you put the title of it originally on your, on your album, was it already a phrase that was kind of in the lexicon? No. Yeah, you created that. I mean, the word brat existed, but it wasn't a, it was. Classical sense, yes. Yes, but no, it wasn't, I don't think at least that it was in the lexicon in that,
以它后来变成的那种方式。以它与人们只是拥有它相关联的方式。我是说，那太酷了。对吧？这有点变成了你。好的。是啊。然后所有的热门歌曲，伙计，都在那张专辑里。我是说，很多都成了热门歌曲。
in the way that it became. In the way that it became associated with people just kind of owning it. I mean, that's so cool. Right? Which is kind of what it kind of became you. Okay. Yeah. And then all the hits, man, off that album. I mean, so many have been hits.
太疯狂了。谢谢。你知道，360，Apple，它们是什么？Von Dutch。Hello Goodbye在豪华版里。是啊，哇。为鲜为人知的曲目Hello Goodbye伸张正义。
It's crazy. Thank you. You know, 360, Apple, what are they? Von Dutch. Hello Goodbye was on the extent like the deluxe version. Yeah, wow. Justice for very little known track. Hello Goodbye.
我喜欢Hello Goodbye。我非常喜欢它。等等，他们还叫那些东西B面吗？技术上不是B面，但它就像一个豪华版。再次，就像你一样，豪华。所以你在埃塞克斯长大，对吧？我无法想象你小时候的样子。你在学校长大时是什么样的，拥有这种天赋，
I like Hello Goodbye. I like it a lot. Wait, do they still call those things B-Sides? It's not technically a B-side, but it's like a deluxe version. Again, just like you, deluxe. So you grew up in Essex, right? I can't picture you as a kid. What were you like at school growing up with this talent
你在这么小的年纪就有了？你知道，我只是觉得，因为你爸爸是苏格兰人，你妈妈是印度人，一种文化，一种感觉比另一种更强烈吗？你知道我的意思吗？在学校对你来说有什么不同吗？我是说，它们在文化上都是存在的，但也都不存在，你知道吗？我想我过着这种生活，周末我会去看我妈妈那边的家人。
that you had at such a young age? You know, I just find it because your dad's Scottish and your mom's Indian, did one culture, did one like feel more present than the other? You know what I mean? Was it different at school for you? I mean, they were both sort of present culturally and also not, you know? I think I kind of lived this life where I would go and see my mom's side of the family at the weekends.
当我周围是他们时，我总是会觉得，我想，更白一些，因为我想我并没有完全连接到某些我并不总是参与的文化部分，你知道吗？然后我想在学校里，我经常会觉得更棕色一些，你知道，更印度一些，只是因为我想我很多学校朋友，他们对印度人的唯一参考点就是《辛普森一家》里的阿普，你知道吗？所以我会有种，你知道，那对他们来说是个笑话。所以我会有种，我无法真正连接那里，我也无法连接我妈妈的家人。所以它是，你知道，但它有点像那种轻微的错位感。是啊，是啊。
And when I was sort of around them, I would always kind of feel, I suppose, more white because I guess I didn't entirely perhaps connect with certain parts of the culture that I wasn't always present for, you know? And then I think in school, I would often feel more brown, you know, and more Indian just because I think a lot of my school friends, their only kind of reference point for an Indian person was a poo from the Simpsons, you know? So I would feel very kind of like, you know, and that would be like a joke for them. So I would be a bit like I couldn't really connect there and I couldn't really connect. with my mom's family. So it was, you know, but it was sort of like that kind of a like slight displacement type thing. Yeah, yeah.
最艰难的年龄对你来说和对我，对大多数人一样吗，比如七年级，八年级，比如13，14岁？就像，那时我发现孩子们最刻薄，我的感情受到的伤害最大，我受到的创伤最深，我仍然坚持。我的意思是，我坚持某些当时真正伤害我的事情，但实际上给了我一点厚脸皮来处理，比如我当时没有那种清晰度。但回想起来，确实有一种，我想，经历一些艰难时刻的好处，
And what was like, was it, was the toughest age for you the same as it is for, certainly for me, for most people, like seventh grade, eighth grade, like 13, 14? Like, that's when I found kids are the meanest and like my feelings got hurt the most and I was scarred the most and I still hold on. My point is I hold on to. certain things that really scarred me back then, but actually gave me a bit of a thicker skin to be able to handle, like I didn't have the sort of clarity back then. But in retrospect, there is sort of, I guess, a benefit to going through some of the tough sledding that happens
在那个年龄。当然，如果你有一个年长的兄弟姐妹，当他们取笑你之类的，现在回想起来，作为一个老古董，我确实回过头来看，现在有了自己的孩子。我确实看到了他们经历的事情，就像，它对我有一点帮助。我当时没看出来。你觉得它有助于塑造你和你现在制作的音乐吗？
at that age. And certainly like if you have an older sibling, when they kind of like tease you and stuff, in retrospect now, being the old timer that I am, I do look back at and having kids of my own now. I do sort of see the stuff they go through as like, it helped me a little bit. I didn't see it at the time. Do you find that it helped shape you and the kind of music you make now?
是啊，我是说，我没有任何兄弟姐妹。所以我没有，我其实认为没有兄弟姐妹意味着你错过了很多冲突。我是说，这其实是坏事。就像我认为有兄弟姐妹的朋友在处理冲突方面要好得多，因为他们不会把它放大成这种巨大的戏剧性事件。他们只是能比我更快地走出来。
Yeah, I mean, I don't have any siblings. So I didn't, I actually think not having siblings actually means that you miss out on a lot of conflict. And I mean that in like actually a bad way. Like I think my friends who have siblings are so much better at conflict as in they don't kind of amplify it up into this huge dramatic thing. It's just they're able to move through it a lot more quickly than I am.
因为他们知道如何化解它，你知道。是啊。作为一个独生子，你受到保护，你被宠坏了，一切都围绕着你。是啊。然后它也是，你真正必须战斗的唯一人就是你的父母，他们是某种权威人物。所以冲突感觉远比这剧烈。而且没有兄弟姐妹来，你知道，只是化解它一点，让它不那么大惊小怪。所以它感觉非常巨大。
Because they know how to diffuse it, you know. Yeah. And as an only child, you're sort of protected and you're coddled and it's all about you. Yeah. And then also it's like the only people you really have to really like fight with is your parents who are this figure of authority in a way. So the clash feels like far more drastic. And there isn't like a sibling to kind of, you know, just diffuse it a bit and make it from less of a big deal. So it feels really gigantic.
这意味着你很想拥有不止一个孩子吗？还是你希望有一个孩子，经历和你一样的体验，或者它是独生子，你可以只是去培养和保护？我其实并不真的想生孩子。不，一个都没有。你不想？等等，为什么？是啊。
Does that mean that you would love to have more than one kid? Or would you like to have a kid that has the same sort of experience as you or it's the only child and you get to just kind of nurture and protect? I actually don't really want to have kids. No, none. You don't? Wait, why? Yeah.
你知道，谁知道呢？那可能会改变。哦，不关我的事。但是，肖尼，你从来没有真正对此感兴趣。对吧？我是说，我说过一百万次我想想要孩子。当然。我丈夫，斯科蒂，是独生子，你可以用这个短语。
You know, who knows? That could change. Oh, it's not of my business. But, Shawnee, you've never really had any interest in it. Right? I mean, I've said it a million times that I want to want to have kids. Sure. And my husband, Scotty, grew up an only child, and you can use this phrase.
他总是说我被宠坏了但没烂掉。对。所以他总是，他必须学习，他必须学习你所说的所有东西。比如如何化解冲突之类的。但是的，我，你知道，什么，我说过一百万次了。在节目上，我宁愿后悔没生孩子，也不愿生了之后以后后悔。对，对，对。
He always says I was spoiled but not rotten. Right. So he was always, he has to learn how, he had to learn everything that you're saying. Like how to diffuse conflict and all that stuff. But yeah, I was, you know, what's, I've said it a million times. on the show that I'd rather regret not having kids than have them and regret it later. Right, right, right.
因为你永远不知道你会得到什么，就像掷骰子。你看过《干预》这个节目吗？就像，如果我有个孩子，那就是他们最终会去的地方，比如，把我拖过街，像个他妈的瘾君子。你会很棒的。他们会很棒的。我是说，我知道你的意思。就像，我喜欢，比如，生孩子的幻想。
Because you never know what you're going to get, like the roll of the dice. Do you ever see the show intervention? It's like, if I had a kid, that's where they would end up, like, dragging me through the street, like, fucking drug addict. You would be great. They would be great. I mean, I know what you mean. It's like, I love, like, the fantasy of having a child.
比如，给它起名字听起来很有趣。但我会想，那对我来说正是为什么我不应该生一个的标志。那感觉像是其中最酷的部分。对，对。而且，也许我还没准备好。你知道我的意思吗？但是，你知道，这一切都可能改变。
Like, like, naming it sounds so fun. But I'm like, that is exactly a sign to me as to why I should not have one. that that feels like the coolest part about it. Right, right. And like, maybe I'm not ready. You know what I mean? But, you know, all that could change.
如果你可能，我的，我的，我是说，我有点，我想我正在退缩，给自己一个半吊子的赞美，但我妻子不想生孩子。故事就是这样。她是这么告诉我的。她没生。你领养了你的。她说一旦，一旦我们开始约会，她就觉得，好吧，我想我可以和这个家伙生个孩子。
If you might, my, my, I mean, I'm sort of, I guess I'm backing in to giving myself a half-ass compliment here, but my wife did not want to have kids. So the story goes. So she tells me. And she didn't. And you adopted yours. And she said once, once we started going out and she was like, okay, I think I can have a kid with this guy.
所以你可能会找到某个人。嗯，我结婚了。哦，那我们走吧。我得有一天读读报纸。你知道，没关系。这就是你在这里的原因。我立刻就知道你要去哪里了。我知道我的回应。
So you might find somebody. Well, I'm married. Oh, there we go. I got to read a newspaper one of these days. You know, it's okay. That's why you're here. I knew immediately like where you were going to go. I knew my response.
我很期待。也许你的下一任丈夫你会想要孩子。是啊，完全正确。让我说完，查理。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目。但是等等，这真的很酷。这太狂野了。
I was looking forward to it. Maybe your next husband you're going to want kids. Yeah, exactly. Let me finish, Charlie. We'll be right back. And now, back to the show. But wait, though, this is really cool. This is so wild.
我不知道这个。所以当你开始，开始所有那些非法仓库时，这是我读到的，所有那些你会去的非法仓库，你会去狂欢派对，你会去那里表演，你的父母不会只是把你放下，他们会和你一起进去，是啊，是啊，我是说我太幸运了，他们当时非常支持，我当时觉得这太逊了，就像他们限制了我的风格，但你知道他们显然只是非常非常支持，我觉得我很幸运，所以你会在这些狂欢派对上表演，对吧？他们还参与你的职业生涯吗？有很多音乐家仍然有参与他们职业生涯的父母。
I did not know this. that so when you start for starting out all the illegal warehouses this is what I read all the illegal warehouses that you would go to you would go to raves and you would what perform there and your parents would not just drop you up they would go inside with you yeah yeah i mean i was so lucky they were very supportive at the time i was like this is so lame like they're cramping my style but you know they were obviously just very very supportive i feel very lucky and so you would play shows at these raves right are they still involved with your career There's a lot of musicians that still have parents that are involved with their career.
非常成功。我的没有，但他们仍然，你知道，他们非常骄傲，非常支持，但他们没有参与我的职业生涯，不。他们给过你关于音乐的建议吗？他们喜欢你的音乐吗？我敢打赌你会。我爸爸过去很喜欢提出一些建议，是的。非常多。
Very successful. Mine aren't, but they're still, you know, they're very proud and they're very supportive, but they're not involved in my career, no. Do they ever give you notes on your music? Do they like your music? I'll bet you do. My dad used to love throwing out some suggestions, yes. Very much so.
曾经，有什么有用的吗？曾经有什么有用的吗？你知道，我想这就像，我为他感到难过，因为我想，我想这是一件即使它是史上最棒的主意，我想纯粹因为，这是，他过去在我小得多的时候经常这样做，比如纯粹因为他是我的爸爸，他总是会得到那个“不”，你知道我的意思吗？对，对，对。但我肯定，你知道，他是个聪明人。
Ever, anything useful? Anything useful, ever? You know, I think it's like, I feel bad for him because I think, think it's one of those things where even if it was the most amazing idea ever, I think purely because, and this is, he used to do this when I was a lot younger, like purely because he was my dad, he was always going to get the no-what, you know what I mean? Right, right, right. But I'm sure, you know, he's a smart guy.
我肯定他可能确实有好的歌曲点子。你能告诉杰森关于你爸爸的故事吗，有人试图在狂欢派对上向你爸爸卖毒品？对。这其实是我妈妈。有人试图在我妈妈参加狂欢派对时向她卖毒品。什么口味？是的。好吧，我得说，所以听着，
I'm sure he probably does have good song ideas up there. Can you tell Jason about the story about your dad, somebody tried to sell drugs to your dad at one of the raves? Right. This was actually my mom. Someone tried to sell some drugs to my mom at a rave. What flavor? Yes. Well, I got to say, so listen,
我们已经17分钟没有威尔·阿内特了，这真的很棒，对吧？有点轻松。这就像这是一个非常有用的实验。威利，如果你生病了或者类似的事情，我们很好。我们有你。是啊。
we've gone 17 minutes without Will Arnett, and it's really been great, trying, hasn't it? Kind of been breezy. It's like this was a very useful experiment. Willie, if you ever have an illness or something like that, we're good. We've got you. Yeah.
或者没有。其实，它真的进行得很顺利。太棒了。我不敢相信这就像我的噩梦。哦，拜托。不是我们在这里为你服务。那边发生了什么？你还好吗？
Or not. Actually, it's really cooking along. great. I can't believe this is like my worst nightmare. Oh, please. Not where we're here for you. What's happening over there? Are you okay?
不，我今天压力很大，查尔斯。我叫你查理吗？是啊，我们已经谈过了。是啊，我们已经谈过了。我有一个，查理，我能说吗，我有一个，我和男孩们分享，我不会深入讨论，但我个人压力很大。
No, I'm having a stressful day, Charles. Do I call you Charlie? Yeah, we've covered it. Yeah, we've covered it. I've had, Charlie, can I just say, I've had a really, I share with the boys, I won't get into it, but I've had a really stressful day on a personal level.
这已经是一个非常，是啊。我很抱歉。你之后会深入讨论的。插入笑话？不。嗯，有一个插入笑话，是啊。问题的一部分，我仍然有它
It's been a very, yeah. I'm sorry. You're going to get into it after. Insert joke here? No. Well, there was an insert joke, yeah. part of the problem I still got it
查理，很抱歉错过了。这不像我。我通常对这种事情很在行。但总之，别担心。这太有趣了。每个人都有，你知道，这是最好的剧集之一
Charlie I'm sorry to have missed it This is unlike me I'm usually pretty good about this kind of stuff But anyway Don't you worry It's so fun Everybody's got like you know This is one of the best episodes
因为查理迟到了一点。你迟到了一点。我总是迟到一点。我避免了一点嘲笑，威尔无疑会给我的，因为我真的把头埋在屁股里，关于查理，就像这里的所有爷爷都需要一点更新
Because Charlie was a little late You were a little late I'm always a little late I avoid a little teasing That Will undoubtedly would have given me For really having my head up my ass About Charlie and like All Granddad here needed a little update
他不知道她是，她生了Brat这个词，你知道，和卡玛拉·哈里斯以及所有那些。我想我也不知道。哇。我知道你是谁。没关系。伙计们，它是，它是，好吧，它是。我非常了解你的音乐和你是谁。应该指出。
He didn't know she was the, she born the term brat, you know, with Kamala Harris and all that. I don't think I knew that either. Wow. I know who you are. It's okay. Guys, it's, it's, well, it's. I'm very aware of your music and who you are. It should be noted.
别担心。我还在听Steely Dan，查理。是啊，那很酷。这是个问题。那很酷。等等，我只是觉得这很有趣。嗯，我刚才在谈论查理的父母过去如何和她一起去她表演的狂欢派对，就像所有这些派对。那很有趣。
Don't you worry. I'm still listening to Steely Dan, Charlie. Yeah, and that's cool. It's a problem. That's cool. Wait, I just thought it was funny. Well, I was talking about how Charlie's parents used to go with her to the raves that she performed at, like all these parties. That's fun.
而且她妈妈被提供了一小袋……嗯，MDMA，但她以为他们说的是MDF，就像你可以买来给墙板装饰的那种木头。我爸爸说，我们确实可以用一些那个，但我不知道我们怎么把它塞进车里。那个人有点像，等等，比如，你想买多少？我只是觉得这是一个非常甜蜜的故事。他有很强的耐受力。
And her mom was offered a baggie of... Of, well, of MDMA, but she thought that they said MDF, as in the wood that you can buy to like panel a wall. And my dad was like, we could use some of that, but I don't know how we're going to fit it in the car. And the guy was kind of like, wait, like, how much do you want to buy? And I just thought it was a very sweet story. He's got a lot of tolerance.
他们能处理很多。是啊，那对我们来说确实非常有用。如果我在家里想一想，我们可以用什么。顺便说一句，这可能不合适。但我听到了很多关于MDMA的消息。再次，回到这里作为一个老古董，我听说这很流行。它是什么？
They can handle a lot. Yeah, that would be really useful for us, actually. If I think about it at the house, what we could use. By the way, this might be inappropriate. But I am hearing a lot about MDMA. Again, getting back to being an old-timer here, I'm hearing it's quite the thing. What is it?
那是马镇静剂吗？不。我想它有点像摇头丸。它有点像摇头丸过去的样子，对吧？对，是啊。我很久以前用过一点，我听说这个MDMA是个好东西。我不提倡尝试或做它，孩子们，
Is that the horse tranquilizer thing? No. I think it's kind of like ecstasy. It's kind of like what ecstasy used to be, right? Right, yeah. I had a little of that way back in the day, and I'm hearing this MDMA is a good time. I'm not advocating trying it or doing it, kids,
但我听说这是一个新东西。嗯，他们现在也做MDMA治疗，我想，对吧？这不是我尝试过的。我从来没做过。我相信它在治疗中，比如周五晚上的治疗。你知道我的意思吗？只有一晚。配上一小杯Tito's。
but I hear it's a new thing. Well, they do MDMA therapy now, I think, as well, right? Which is not something that I've tried. I've never done it. I believe it in therapy, like a Friday night therapy. You know what I mean? Just one night. With like a little sidecar of Tito's.
任何你喜欢的东西。任何让它下去更容易的东西，你知道吗？明白了。天哪。好的，所以等等。所以我想知道，好的，所以我想谈谈，比如，进入音乐圈。所以你记得第一次吗？因为我觉得你的故事太迷人了，你那么年轻，你开始，你发现你在这么小的年纪就有这种天赋，你有点像个超级巨星，你飞在
Whatever it is that you like. Whatever makes it go down a little better, you know? Gotcha. Oh, my God. Okay, so wait. So I want to know, okay, so I want to talk about, like, getting in the music stuff. So do you remember the first time? Because I find your story so fascinating that you were so young, and you started, you discovered you had this talent at such a young age, and you were kind of like a superstar, and you flew under
雷达之下。然后，你知道，我认识你可能，比如，世界认识你是因为那个，“我不在乎。我喜欢它。”就像那首歌。太巨大了。不，我只做了。我不在乎。我喜欢它。
the radar. And then, you know, I knew you probably, like, the world knew you with the, I love it. I don't care. Like that song. So huge. No, I only did. I don't care. I love it.
但你并没有真正，比如，出现在视频里，我觉得这很奇怪。而且，比如，知道你写了这首歌，这是你的歌，但没有你的脸在上面，可以说，取得成功是什么感觉？是啊，不。我是说，这很有趣。我的职业生涯有点，比如，奇怪，因为我，比如，做了很多事情，有一些真的，真的很大的热门歌曲。但我经常要么是这首歌的作者，
But you weren't really, like, featured in the video, which I thought was weird. And, like, so what would that like knowing you wrote this song, and this was your song, but was having the success without your face on it, kind of, so to speak? Yeah, no. I mean, it was funny. I had a really sort of, like, strange career in that, like, I was kind of, like, doing a lot of stuff and had some really, really big hits. But I was often either the writer of the song
要么是这首歌的特色，所以，比如，没人真正知道我是谁。所以我确实，正如你刚才所说，完全飞在雷达之下。比如，我去做很酷的事情，比如和不可思议的人一起工作，环游世界，但也完全匿名。所以这非常，这非常，比如，有趣。
or the feature of the song, and so, like, nobody really knew who I was. So I did, exactly, as you just said, like completely fly under the radar. Like, I was going to cool shit, like working with incredible people, traveling the world, but was also kind of completely anonymous. So it was very, it was, like, interesting.
而且其实非常有用，我想，对我来说，特别是我的上一张唱片《Brat》，它确实让我接触到了更广泛的受众。我想如果我没有在2013年、2014年那样经历这些，比如，老实说，比如，大的排行榜冠军歌曲，我现在可能完全，比如，疯了，因为我不会真正准备好。
And very actually useful, I think, for me, especially with my previous record, Brat, which really did kind of open me to a much wider audience. I think had I not had that experience back in like 2013, 2014 of these like, honestly, like, big chart-topping songs, I probably would be like totally like off my head right now because I wouldn't really be prepared.
你知道我的意思吗？对，对。所以，我会是一个彻底的噩梦，也许我现在仍然是。我不知道我的意思吗？不，你不是。你不是。所以，是啊，这很有趣，
Do you know what I mean? Right, right. So, and I would be like a complete nightmare, which maybe I still am. I don't know what I mean? No, you're not. You're not. So, yeah, it was interesting,
而且它有点像从那时到现在的那些年里，已经，比如，建立了我的受众，比如，以一种非常，比如，缓慢的，有机的方式。对，对。所以是啊，这是一条有趣的道路。告诉他们，告诉这些家伙，继续吧，你有自由去吹嘘你为之写歌的所有艺术家。不是全部，但比如，你知道。
and it's kind of like over those years from then to now have sort of like built my like audience, like sort of in a very kind of slow, like organic way. Right, right. So yeah, it's been a kind of interesting path. And tell me, tell these guys, just go ahead, you have free reign to brag all the artists you've written songs for. Not all, but like the, you know.
所以你会一直为其他艺术家写歌。你不一定想自己表演的。是的。热门歌曲。是啊。你怎么决定？比如，好的，
So you'll write songs for other artists all the time. That you don't necessarily want to perform yourself. Yes. Big hit songs. Yeah. How do you decide? Like, okay,
所以你经常会为其他艺人写歌。那些你未必想亲自演唱的歌。是的。大热单曲。是的。你是怎么决定的呢？比如，好吧，
Selena Gomez, Iggy Azalea, Camila Cabo. Camila Cabo, yeah. Wow. Sean Mendez, right. James Blunt, randomly. Do you write them for them
赛琳娜·戈麦斯、伊基·阿塞莉娅、卡米拉·卡贝洛。卡米拉·卡贝洛，对。哇。肖恩·门德斯，对吧。还有詹姆斯·布朗特，挺随意的。你是为他们写的歌吗？
or you write them thinking that you might do it or they just become a, you're like, hey, I've got a song that I've written or somebody comes to you and says, Charlie Hay, I've got an idea, do this for me. Or can you just write me a song? How does that... It goes every way.
还是你写的时候想着自己可能会唱，或者他们只是变成了一个……你就像是，嘿，我有一首歌写好了，或者有人来找你说，查莉，我有个想法，帮我做这个。或者你能帮我写首歌吗？这通常是怎么……各种方式都有。
All of those ways are options. Sometimes it's kind of like a... We need songs for XYZ artist and this is what they want to say. And then sometimes it's like, I'll write a song and I'll be like, oh, I thought this was for me, but actually, like, I don't think I should sing like a sort of flamenco-sounding, like, pop song
所有这些方式都是可能的。有时就像是……我们需要给某某艺人写歌，这就是他们想表达的内容。有时又像是，我写了一首歌，然后我会想，哦，我以为这是给我的，但实际上，我觉得我不应该唱那种听起来像弗拉门戈风格的流行歌曲，
because that doesn't make it. make sense for me as an artist. What you're writing is the music or the lyrics or both in these cases? I write like the lyrics and the top line, which is sort of the melody that the singer sings. Right. Incredible. Yeah. Because I was surprised a few years ago, I learned that, you know, that it's not that
因为作为艺人，这对我来说没意义。你写的是音乐还是歌词，或者在这些情况下两者都有？我写歌词和顶线，也就是歌手唱的那种旋律。对。太不可思议了。是啊，因为几年前我很惊讶，我了解到，你知道，这并不
that uncommon for some of the biggest stars in the world to not write anything ever. It's all incoming. They're just the same. I don't mean to belittle it. They only do the singing and everything else is kind of taken care of. Yeah, but you know what? It's funny. I think there's a real stigma against that, you know,
罕见，世界上一些最大的明星从来不写任何东西。一切都是现成的。他们只是负责演唱，其他一切都由别人打理。是啊，但你知道吗？这很有趣。我觉得对此有一种真正的污名化，你知道，
like that that sort of in some ways, like, makes those people like less of an artist. But I don't really agree with that. I think there's like different types of artistry. Like there's someone who's, there's like a great performer versus a great writer versus a great entertainer versus a really like unbelievable vocalist. I think there's sort of. It would also be like the equivalent, sorry, be the equivalent of like an actor just acting
就好像在某些方面，这让那些人看起来不那么像个艺术家。但我并不完全同意这一点。我认为艺术有不同的类型。比如有伟大的表演者，有伟大的创作者，有伟大的艺人，还有真正令人难以置信的歌手。我认为有某种……这就像是演员只负责演戏，
versus somebody who's also, who writes and directs and produces as well as act. It's like it's really cool that you can do all of those things. Yeah, I mean, I enjoy it. I mean, wait until this movie comes out. And how did that, were one of your parents musically inclined, did they kind of put the bug in you? No, not really. How did you find it?
而另一个人不仅演戏，还负责编剧、导演和制片。能做到所有这些事情真的很酷。是啊，我的意思是，我很享受。等等，等这部电影上映吧。那是怎么回事，你的父母有音乐天赋吗，他们是否在你心中种下了这颗种子？不，其实没有。你是怎么发现它的？
I think it was, I just, I played piano. Yeah. Growing up, I was sort of studying classical piano. Oh, shawnee. And I, when I was younger, I had no interest in classical music at all. I didn't think it was cool. I didn't get it. Now I feel completely different.
我想是因为，我只是，我弹钢琴。是啊。成长过程中，我一直在学习古典钢琴。哦，肖尼。当我年轻的时候，我对古典音乐一点兴趣都没有。我觉得它不酷。我不理解它。现在我的感觉完全不同了。
I love classical music. All I listen to. But at the time, I really didn't, I didn't relate to it. And I thought it was kind of embarrassing that I was doing it. So instead, I really was trying to, like, write pop songs and chords and kind of escape out of this classical stuff that I was learning. But that background in that, it must have helped you sort of songwriting-wise. Yes.
我热爱古典音乐。我只听这个。但在当时，我真的没有，我无法与它产生共鸣。我觉得我这样做有点尴尬。所以相反，我真的在尝试写流行歌曲和和弦，试图逃离我正在学习的这些古典东西。但那种背景，一定在某种程度上对你的歌曲创作有帮助。是的。
Yeah, Elton John talks about that, how that informed a lot of his writing. You know what? It's interesting because I, so when I was studying classical music, I was really basically just doing it to pass the, grades, like the classical grades. And each grade, you would have to learn three pieces of music and then you would do an exam where you would play the pieces of music. And you would also do like site reading and another test.
是啊，埃尔顿·约翰谈到过这一点，它是如何影响了他的很多创作。你知道吗？这很有趣，因为我，当我学习古典音乐时，我基本上只是为了通过考试，比如古典音乐等级考试。每一级，你都必须学习三首乐曲，然后参加考试，演奏这些乐曲。你还要做视奏和其他测试。
I can't remember what it was. But I actually couldn't read music. I always really had like trouble reading the music and playing what was there. So I would spend an entire year like learning and practicing these pieces by ear instead of like actually just being able to pick up any piece of music and read it. Yeah, it's called like the Suzuki method, yeah. Sure, I think so, yeah. And so, so, like, I, um, so I, like, couldn't really, like, read any other music.
我不记得是什么了。但我其实不会看乐谱。我一直很难看懂乐谱并演奏出来。所以我花了一整年时间通过听觉来学习和练习这些曲子，而不是真正能够拿起任何乐谱就读出来。是啊，这叫铃木教学法，对吧。当然，我想是这样，是的。所以，我，嗯，我，就像，真的不能读任何其他乐谱。
So I actually have a really, like, low-level knowledge of classical music. So when Elton John's like, oh, yeah, for me it really helped, that's probably because he's obviously fucking Elton John and can probably play, you know, any single thing ever. But I could only really hear things by ear. Right, and also, like, to the extent you feel comfortable talking about synesthesia, because I think it's fascinating. Do you guys know what that is? No. Is it where you see music? You see color. You see music in colors.
所以我对古典音乐的知识水平其实很低。所以当埃尔顿·约翰说，哦，是的，对我来说它真的很有帮助，那可能是因为他显然是该死的埃尔顿·约翰，可能能演奏任何东西。但我真的只能凭听觉来感知事物。对，还有，在你觉得舒服的范围内谈谈联觉，因为我觉得这很迷人。你们知道那是什么吗？不知道。是看到音乐吗？你看到颜色。你用颜色来看音乐。
Oh, really? Yeah. Can you describe that and how you first found out you had that and how you use it today? Yeah, I mean, it's funny. It's like, I think it's not just about music. It can be, I don't know, some people might be like see the days of the week in colors. It's a kind of color association to a thing and different people have different stuff. I have that. You have that? Yeah, for certain things I have, but I've never thought about it.
哦，真的吗？是啊。你能描述一下吗，你是怎么发现自己有这个能力的，以及你今天是如何使用它的？是啊，我的意思是，这很有趣。我想这不仅仅是关于音乐。可能是，我不知道，有些人可能会把一周的日子看成颜色。这是一种对事物的颜色联想，不同的人有不同的东西。我有这个。你有吗？是啊，对于某些事情我有，但我从来没想过。
But yeah. Really? Wow. For days of the week, you said days of the week, days of the week, days of the weeks have colors for me. Wow, you've just been diagnosed by Charlie and you didn't even know how you had it. I don't know, yeah. And so do you put, what colors Wednesday? Pink.
但确实。真的吗？哇。对于一周的日子，你说一周的日子，一周的日子，一周的日子对我来说是有颜色的。哇，你刚被查莉诊断了，你甚至不知道自己有这个。我不知道，是啊。那你把周三定为什么颜色？粉色。
What? You just made that up. No. Thursday's green. Friday. Friday's orange, Saturday's blue, Sunday's yellow, Monday's blue. Our Fridays, you're in love?
什么？你刚编出来的吧。不。周四是绿色。周五。周五是橙色，周六是蓝色，周日是黄色，周一也是蓝色。我们的周五，你恋爱了吗？
Tuesday's red. Friday's you're in love. I don't care what money. It's going to cost us to. But anyway, sorry, but it's not as evolved as yours. No, I mean, so it's basically just for me, it's like I was, when I first started realizing that I guess I had it, and I didn't really know what it was when I was sort of figuring it out,
周二是红色。周五你恋爱了。我不在乎要花多少钱。但总之，抱歉，但这不像你的那么进化。不，我的意思是，所以对我来说基本上就是，当我第一次开始意识到我大概有这个能力时，我当时并不知道那是什么，当我试图弄清楚它时，
was when I was working with producers and I would sort of say, like, can you make this sound more blue or more purple? And I wouldn't quite be able to articulate specifically the sound design that I needed, but I just knew that it needed to sound purple. And then when the producer would help generate that sound, I would say, like, that's it, that's the purple.
是我在和制作人合作时，我会说，你能让这个声音听起来更蓝或更紫吗？我无法准确表达我需要的具体声音设计，但我只是知道它需要听起来是紫色的。然后当制作人帮助生成那个声音时，我会说，就是这个，这就是紫色。
That's purple or whatever. And so now do you have to work with that producer all the time? Well, yeah, I mean, I do work with the same people quite a lot. I mean, they know. They definitely know what I mean. when I say something. Have you ever tried, like, I don't know how to explain this. Have you ever, like, listen to one of your own songs
那是紫色什么的。所以现在你必须一直和那个制作人合作吗？嗯，是啊，我的意思是，我确实经常和同样的人合作。我的意思是，他们知道。他们绝对知道我说话的意思。你有没有试过，我不知道怎么解释这个。你有没有试过，听你自己的歌
and tried to paint it as you've listened to it? Yeah, so it's going to ask that. I haven't, actually, but I think I do sort of like see it, kind of. And when I listen to other music, I kind of like, I see it in a way. I'm like, oh, this song evokes this color immediately. And do you ever reverse engineer that? And for inspiration, when you write a song, Like, you know, we always ask a lot of musicians, what comes first, the lyrics or the music.
然后试着在你听的时候把它画出来？是啊，正要问这个。我其实没试过，但我觉得我确实能看到它，某种程度上。当我听其他音乐时，我也会以某种方式看到它。我会想，哦，这首歌立刻唤起了这种颜色。你有没有反向工程过？为了灵感，当你写歌时，你知道，我们总是问很多音乐家，是歌词先来还是音乐先来。
Do you ever see a color first, and then music comes from that? More recently, no. It's really generated specifically by when I hear sound. Then I start thinking about color. But on this last record, to be honest, a lot of the songs were generated from, like, lyrical-based ideas. Like, I was really leading with lyrics. Is that new? Is that, like, a departure from... Yeah, yeah, because I used to kind of write phonetically where I would sort of...
你有没有先看到颜色，然后音乐随之而来？最近没有。它真的是在我听到声音时专门生成的。然后我开始思考颜色。但在上一张唱片上，老实说，很多歌都是从基于歌词的想法中生成的。比如，我真的在以歌词为主导。这是新的吗？这是对……的背离吗？是啊，是啊，因为我过去习惯于拼音式写作，我会……
of go into the booth and just kind of record like a kind of like an ad lib track where I'd be like like blah blah blah blah and then I would fit like lyrics to the vowel sounds that I was creating. Yeah, that's cool. But now, yeah, more recently I'm becoming much more lyric led because I think I, on the last record I had some like really specific stories that I wanted to tell and I didn't feel. and I didn't feel, I don't know, I just felt like I really wanted to kind of throw out any like tropes that I had previously used in the past. Like I particularly wasn't interested in rhyme with this record. I just wanted to like say the direct dialogue from my brain in the way that I would text a friend.
走进录音棚，录下一段即兴曲目，我会说，比如，啦啦啦啦，然后我会把歌词填进我创造的元音里。是啊，那很酷。但现在，是啊，最近我变得更加以歌词为主导，因为我觉得，在上一张唱片上，我有一些非常具体的故事想讲，我不想，我不知道，我只是觉得我真的想抛弃我过去使用过的任何陈词滥调。比如，这张唱片我特别不想押韵。我只是想说出我大脑中的直接对话，就像我给朋友发短信那样。
Like I think that became like kind of the tone of the record. Yeah. So are you ever doing it on piano based on your sort of your history with piano? Do you ever do that? To be honest, no. my music is very electronic. Yeah. And kind of, especially on the last record,
我觉得那成了这张唱片的基调。是啊。那你还在钢琴上做吗，基于你那种钢琴背景？你还会那样做吗？老实说，没有。我的音乐非常电子化。是啊。而且，特别是在上一张唱片上，
like very club-based dance music. So I wasn't really going to the piano too much. But given what you were saying about how you're much more lyric-driven right now, there's certain things that you really like talking about and saying and communicating, how important is it to you that people hear every word in the lyrics? Because, like, I'll try to follow lyrics. And, you know, some folks, they don't really, you know, they won't screw up the song to enunciate, you know.
非常像夜店风格的舞曲。所以我并没有太多地去碰钢琴。但鉴于你刚才说的你现在更以歌词为驱动，有些事情你真的很想谈论、表达和交流，人们听到歌词中的每一个字对你来说有多重要？因为，我会试着去跟歌词。而且，你知道，有些人，他们真的不会，他们不会为了咬字清晰而毁掉这首歌，你知道。
Sometimes it sounds better to just kind of mumble it out. And I get that. Yeah. But you're like, motherfucker, I want to hear what you're saying. Yeah. That's what you look on Apple Music for the lyrics, right? Right, right. I do that too.
有时含糊地唱出来听起来更好。我明白这一点。但你会想，该死，我想听清楚你在说什么。是啊。这就是你在Apple Music上查歌词的原因，对吧？对，对。我也那样做。
I don't really care about enunciation, to be honest. I think it's if you... Overrated. Yeah, it's overrated. And also, I'd love to hear, you know, your interstate. of what I'm saying rather than what I'm actually saying because, you know, no one fact checks anyway anymore. So it's fun to just play into it.
老实说，我并不在乎咬字清晰。我觉得如果……被高估了。是啊，被高估了。而且，我也很乐意听到，你知道，你对我所说内容的解读，而不是我实际在说的内容，因为，你知道，反正现在也没人核实事实。所以玩玩这个很有趣。
Yeah, yeah. Sorry, Sean, go ahead. No, I was just going to say, how do you know when a song, I don't think we've ever asked this of any musician on the show. How do you know what a song is done? Because it's like in film editing, you could just do it forever. Like you could just tweak and tweak and tweak. So for you, when you write, all these massive hit songs, this long list of all these huge
是啊，是啊。抱歉，肖恩，你继续。不，我只是想说，你怎么知道一首歌什么时候完成了？我想我们从来没在节目里问过任何音乐家这个问题。你怎么知道一首歌完成了？因为这就像电影剪辑，你可以永远做下去。你可以一直调整、调整、再调整。所以对你来说，当你写歌时，所有这些巨大的热门歌曲，这长长的一串巨大的
songs that how do you know when you're done? I mean, I think it's different for everyone, but for me, I mean, people can go for ages on a song as well and really like chip back into it over and over again in the way that you would with an edit. But for me, that's my nightmare. Like I think there's a real charm in spontaneity. And that's like a big part of my process as an artist, as a writer. It's really that like instinctual kind of first reaction to something
歌曲，你怎么知道你完成了？我的意思是，我觉得每个人都不一样，但对我来说，我的意思是，人们也可以在一首歌上花很长时间，像剪辑一样一遍又一遍地修补它。但对我来说，那是我的噩梦。我觉得自发性有一种真正的魅力。那是我作为艺术家、作为创作者过程中的很大一部分。真的是那种对某事的第一反应，那种本能，
that there is something almost like charming and naive to it sometimes. You know when you're a kid and you're coming up with ideas? Like if a kid writes a song, sometimes they could like say something so profound and like actually really surreal and abstract that as an adult it might take you a while to kind of think of or something and then it might even feel too forced. I feel like that's, for me, it's like the same when I'm writing.
有时它有一种几乎是迷人且天真的东西。你知道当你还是个孩子，想出点子的时候吗？如果一个孩子写了一首歌，有时他们能说出一些如此深刻、实际上非常超现实和抽象的东西，作为一个成年人，你可能需要花点时间才能想到，或者甚至可能感觉太刻意了。我觉得，对我来说，当我写作时也是一样。
I'm like, the first idea is often just way more, I don't know, like, unique than when I've sat down and really thought about it for a while. So I really try and just like capture the moment in that kind of a way. Do you know, do you know when you have finished a song, do you ever get that sense where you go, this is a hit song? I can feel it and, for real. I mean, you must have those. I do, but it's like those ones are always the ones that actually end up sucking.
我心想，第一个想法往往比我坐下来认真思考一段时间后的想法要独特得多。所以我真的尽量捕捉那一刻。你知道，当你完成一首歌时，你有没有那种感觉，你会说，这是一首热门歌曲？我能感觉到，真的。我的意思是，你一定有过那种时刻。我有，但那些往往是最终结果很烂的歌。
You know what I mean? It's like, I mean, it's like, I'm sure, I don't know if you guys have this when you're writing or when you're performing. If ever you think you kill it, you probably didn't. You know what I mean? It's like one of those moments. And also, if it's immediately catchy, you can get sick of it really quick. and those are the ones that are probably too simplistic
你知道我的意思吗？我的意思是，我敢肯定，我不知道你们在写作或表演时是否有这种感觉。如果你觉得你表现得太棒了，你可能并没有。你知道我的意思吗？这就像那种时刻之一。而且，如果它立刻朗朗上口，你很快就会厌倦它。而那些可能太简单了，
or a public might get tired of too fast, and it doesn't have important. Possibly. I also think it's funny. I think we're in this kind of new era of creativity as a whole. I definitely feel this way about writing songs. I don't know how you guys feel about this, but I think we live in such a reference-heavy world now that I think things can kind of become catchy or earworms
或者公众可能很快就会厌倦，而且它没有重要性。可能吧。我也觉得很有趣。我认为我们正处于一个全新的创造力时代。我绝对是这样看待写歌的。我不知道你们对此有何感想，但我认为我们现在生活在一个如此依赖参考的世界里，我认为事情可能会变得朗朗上口，或者成为洗脑神曲，
or something that you want to revisit, for other reasons outside of maybe they're like really dynamically written or the melody is technically good. It could actually just be you're referencing something that's so within the zeitgeist, that that itself is like the hook of it. And I think that's a really interesting way of writing. Like it's more like topical writing.
或者你想重温的东西，原因可能不是因为它们写得非常有活力，或者旋律在技术上很好。它可能只是因为你引用了某种非常符合时代精神的东西，而那本身就是它的钩子。我认为这是一种非常有趣的写作方式。这更像是主题写作。
Well, I think that that probably happens a lot. We have like, think about all the, you know, the songs that we love sort of for nostalgic reasons, right? that other people might be like, yeah, that song doesn't really mean much to me? You're like, really? Doesn't it remind you of that summer when we were 17? They're like, no, not really.
嗯，我想这种情况可能经常发生。我们有，想想所有那些，你知道，我们出于怀旧原因而喜爱的歌曲，对吧？其他人可能会说，是的，那首歌对我来说没什么意义？你会说，真的吗？它难道不让你想起我们17岁时的那个夏天吗？他们会说，不，真的没有。
Yeah, sorry. Right, right, for sure. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. What's the turnaround time for a song? Because if you were trying to follow trend with film, it'd be a fool's errand because it takes about a year to turn a movie around
是啊，抱歉。对，对，当然。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。一首歌的周转时间是多少？因为如果你试图追随电影的趋势，那将是徒劳的，因为从开始剪辑到发行一部电影至少需要一年时间，
from when you started to cut it to release it, I mean, at a minimum. How long does it take to turn a song around? I could, like, a day. I mean, I mean, sometimes you write, I wrote, I love it in 30 minutes, which is the one that you were singing amazingly. But it's not, that's not me being like, aren't I amazing? I mean, the lyrics are like on repeat.
我的意思是，至少。完成一首歌需要多长时间？我可以，比如，一天。我的意思是，我的意思是，有时你写，我写《I Love It》用了30分钟，就是你们唱得非常棒的那首。但这并不是，那不是我在说，我不棒吗？我的意思是，歌词就像在循环播放。
It's not, you know what I mean? It's like, but it's just, I think it's just like, we have this saying like me and a couple of my collaborators where it's like, you have to dare to suck, right? And sometimes in like daring to suck, actually the most fucking like universal genius idea comes out where you're just being stupid. I've been daring to suck my whole life by it.
不是，你知道我的意思吗？这就像，但我认为这就像，我们有一个说法，我和我的几个合作者，就是说，你必须敢于糟糕，对吧？有时在敢于糟糕的过程中，实际上最该死的、像普遍天才般的想法就出来了，你只是在装傻。我一生都在敢于糟糕。
If I'm being honest. If I was sitting in a studio and I was writing, I mean, I could 360 Apple, whatever. But since you said it, I love it, I don't care. And I would be like, guys, what about this? I love it. I don't care. I wouldn't have the confidence to be like,
如果我诚实的话。如果我坐在录音室里写作，我的意思是，我可以360度全方位苹果，随便什么。但既然你说了，我喜欢它，我不在乎。我会说，伙计们，这个怎么样？我喜欢它。我不在乎。我没有信心说，
yeah, I think that's going to work. You know what I mean? But that's it, right? It's like commitment to the bit, you know? Yeah. That's all it is. It's like if I like came to you guys with my tail between my legs and like sung those words, like, fucking whatever. But if I like tell you know this is like fucking the shit and it's so good.
是啊，我觉得那会奏效。你知道我的意思吗？但这就是重点，对吧？这就像对这个片段的承诺，你知道吗？是啊。就是这样。就像如果我垂头丧气地来到你们面前，唱出那些歌词，就像，该死的随便什么。但如果我告诉你们，这简直太棒了，太好了。
And like it's even if you think it's dumb, it's like that's the point. I'm so inspired by you right now. It is. I mean, I am too. Like where did you get that from, Charlie? Yeah. And that's a great environment to provide. for the people around you.
即使你觉得它很蠢，那也是重点。我现在被你深深地激励了。确实。我的意思是，我也是。查莉，你是从哪里得到那个的？是啊。这是一个很好的环境，为你周围的人提供。
You must enjoy that leadership position of creating harmony and your works so it feels safe and there's no bad ideas. We can be foolish. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I think, yeah, it's fun. I think there's this idea that I sometimes disagree with
你一定很享受那种创造和谐的领导地位，你的作品让人感觉安全，没有坏主意。我们可以变得愚蠢。是啊。是啊。我的意思是，我想，是啊，这很有趣。我认为有这种观点，我有时不同意，
that like making good art has to be hard. And like sometimes I really disagree with that. But sometimes I'm like, no, I'm in pain and I'm a real art. and I like to kind of like penduling swing between both of those things. But I don't know. I think, yeah, it's funny. I'm always very, I have always been very interested in, like,
即创作好的艺术必须很困难。有时我真的不同意这一点。但有时我会想，不，我很痛苦，我是一个真正的艺术家。我喜欢在两者之间摇摆。但我不知道。我想，是啊，这很有趣。我一直非常，我一直对，
the connectivity between high and low. That's always just been like something that's been really inspiring to me. And I think that whole like daring to suck mentality, it's very sort of like, I don't know, like factory warholian in a way. It's like paint the soup, just fucking paint it. Yeah, well, I think that it's also about the idea of like, I remember having this teacher once years ago telling me like art is absence of ego. Like if you can get to the place where you're not judging it in real time where you can let go
高雅与低俗之间的联系非常感兴趣。这对我来说一直是非常鼓舞人心的。我认为那种敢于糟糕的心态，非常像，我不知道，像安迪·沃霍尔式的。就像画那个汤罐头，该死的，画出来就行了。是啊，嗯，我认为这也关乎那种想法，我记得多年前有一位老师告诉我，艺术是自我的缺失。如果你能到达那个你没有实时评判它的地方，如果你能放手，
and you guys know what it means too when you're doing what we do or whatever, where you can get to that place where you're not judging it and you're just in the, for lack of a better word, flow and you're just in that thing. Yeah. That's that pocket when you didn't get. Those two, the people you're around, they'll yes and it. Yeah, yes. And you can kind of, and they're like, you don't worry about it.
你们也知道这意味着什么，当我们做我们所做的事情时，或者无论什么，如果你能到达那个你没有评判它，你只是在，用一个更好的词来说，心流中，你只是在那件事里。是啊。那是那个口袋，当你没有得到时。那两个，你周围的人，他们会附和它。是啊，是的。而且你可以某种程度上，他们就像，你不用担心它。
You're not worried about the result of it. You're not thinking about how it's coming across. You're not thinking, you get out of the results and just, then those moments are magic. Yeah. Yeah. I totally agree. And what I also think, and I'm not sure of you guys feel this way, but I think the second I try and write for someone else or to appeal to lots of people. It's like everything kind of falls apart
你不担心它的结果。你不考虑它给人的印象。你不考虑，你跳出结果，只是，然后那些时刻就是魔法。是啊。是啊。我完全同意。而且我还有个想法，我不确定你们是否有这种感觉，但我认为我试图为别人写歌，或者试图吸引很多人时，一切都会分崩离析，
and actually it's like that more like potent vision where maybe you're even just like selfishly writing for yourself really like directly about your experience or your experience with one friend or like whatever it is like the more kind of like potent and distilled it is it weirdly actually then becomes something that more people can relate to because it's so singular.
实际上，这更像是一种更有力的愿景，也许你甚至只是自私地为自己写作，非常直接地关于你的经历，或者你和一个朋友的经历，或者无论它是什么，它越有力、越纯粹，奇怪的是，它反而变成了一种更多人能产生共鸣的东西，因为它如此独特。
Because you believe it and you're doing it for you And what's funny is we live in this world increasingly because of whatever, social media, et cetera, where we do, it is all about this. There is so much feedback constantly on what we do. So it's harder and harder to get away from that. And what's funny is, just hearing you say it, is that we need to kind of reject that. In order to make something really pure in that way, we need to reject the idea of what other people will like, even though the final product of what we do
因为你相信它，而且你是为你自己做的。有趣的是，我们生活在这个世界上，因为无论什么，社交媒体等等，我们确实，一切都是关于这个的。我们所做的一切都有太多的反馈。所以很难摆脱这一点。有趣的是，听到你这么说，我们需要某种程度上拒绝它。为了以那种方式创造出真正纯粹的东西，我们需要拒绝别人会喜欢什么的观点，尽管我们所做事情的最终产品
is for public consumption. Mass public consumption, too. You know, so it's kind of contradictory to the exercise in a way, and yet that's the thing. Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, it is a conflict for sure.
是供公众消费的。也是大众消费。你知道，所以这在某种程度上与练习相矛盾，但这就是重点。是啊。是啊，是啊，是啊。是啊，这确实是一个冲突。
With all the success you've had, Charlie, like three Grammys, and one Grammy show, in one year? at the same show. That's crazy. Yeah. Three Grammys. What, and you see,
查莉，你取得了所有的成功，比如三座格莱美奖，在一次格莱美颁奖典礼上，在一年内？在同一场演出上。那太疯狂了。是啊。三座格莱美奖。什么，而且你看，
and like I keep saying over and over, I'm just like so impressed by your talent at such a young age that you, somebody, your parents, you, whoever, encouraged you to keep going with that. And then now that you are older and knock on wood, hopefully wiser, what's the part of the music industry
而且我一直在说，我只是对你如此年轻就展现出的才华印象深刻，你，某人，你的父母，你，无论谁，鼓励你继续坚持下去。现在你年纪大了，敲敲木头，希望更明智了，音乐产业中哪一部分
that shocked you the most, you know, once you were actually inside of it? You know, like if you knew then what you know now? Just how, no one really knows what they're doing. Right. Isn't that the truth? That is the truth.
最让你震惊，你知道，一旦你真正进入其中？你知道，如果你当时就知道你现在所知道的？只是，没有人真正知道他们在做什么。对吧。这不是事实吗？这就是事实。
It's very funny. It's just sort of... And you thought the difference. Yeah, I was like, oh, this must be run by a really like tight ship of people who like know what's up. And no. It's like, it's not really the case.
这非常有趣。这只是某种……你以为区别。是啊，我当时想，哦，这一定是由一群真正知道内情的人管理的。不。这就像，事实并非如此。
Nor is it, I think, ever the case in any sort of like creative field. It's like the artists know what they're doing and then hopefully you have people with brains to facilitate you and then not annoying really is like kind of the vibe right yeah yeah it's funny do you feel like they're like kind of also you you create the stuff and then the business sort of reacts to it they're much more reactionary rather right so and then they're always trying to recreate with other people like that whole
我认为在任何创意领域都不是这样。艺术家知道他们在做什么，然后希望你有聪明的人来协助你，而且不烦人，这才是那种氛围，对吧，是啊，是啊，这很有趣。你觉得他们是否也，你创造了东西，然后商业某种程度上对此做出反应，他们更具反动性，对吧？所以，他们总是试图用其他人来重现，那种整个
idea yeah and and you know what like I think when I was younger that used to really bother me but I I think now you know it doesn't I think that's just obviously that's just the way it is it's like I couldn't be a record label exec. Like I couldn't work like at distribution company. Like I, you know, it's like I, that's not the brain that I have. I have a different kind of brain where I'm like, why don't we fly planes through the sky that say Brat summer or whatever? You know, it's like, and then they figure out how to do it.
想法，是啊，而且你知道吗，我想当我年轻的时候，这真的让我很困扰，但我认为现在，你知道，它没有了，我认为这显然就是这样。就像我不可能成为唱片公司高管。我不可能在发行公司工作。就像我，你知道，这就像我，那不是我拥有的那种大脑。我有一种不同的大脑，我会想，为什么我们不让飞机在天空中飞过，上面写着“Brat summer”或者什么？你知道，然后他们想出怎么做。
Like, I don't know. It's like, but I did used to be sort of frustrated by why can't you all be on my page with my ideas but actually that would be a nightmare because then it would be less about me which would be awful right right right all right do you remember the first time you walked on stage and felt like um the wall of sound coming at you and like uh wow like just that feeling of like was it were you like oh shit i didn't think it was going to be like this or that's too many people yeah exactly you know no i think because my career was such a slow burn like when i started when I was 15, I was playing to like rooms of three people and that was like my two parents and the promoter.
就像，我不知道。就像，但我确实曾经因为为什么你们不能和我的想法保持一致而感到沮丧，但实际上那将是一场噩梦，因为那样的话，关于我的东西就会变少，那将是可怕的，对吧，对吧，好吧，你还记得第一次走上舞台，感觉到那种……声浪向你袭来，就像……哇，就像那种感觉，你是觉得，哦，该死，我没想到会是这样，或者那是太多人了，是啊，完全正确，你知道，不，我想因为我的职业生涯是一个缓慢的过程，当我15岁开始时，我是在为三个人表演，那是我父母和推广人。
Do you know what I mean? I was like welcoming more people in a way. And over the past sort of 10, 15 years, like it's really grown like gradually and gradually and gradually from like 100 cap rooms to 1,000 rooms to now finally being in arenas. and the first time when I did step out into playing an arena, I just remember being like, well, there's going to be no one there. And all the tickets have been bought by bots. Like that is what I convinced myself in my mind. I was like, no, it's going to be so embarrassing.
你知道我的意思吗？我是在以一种方式欢迎更多的人。在过去的10、15年里，它确实逐渐地、逐渐地、逐渐地增长，从100人的房间到1000人的房间，到现在终于进入了体育馆。而我第一次踏上体育馆表演时，我只记得当时想，好吧，那里一个人都没有。所有的票都被机器人买走了。我就是这样在心里说服自己的。我当时想，不，那会太尴尬了。
All the tickets are gone, but they're all bots. Like, you know? And so it was like a really pleasant surprise. So on this film, was it, was it? Was it just purely for like a musical film to sort of augment the musical venture and all that stuff? Or was there a bit of an acting sort of curiosity there too? And if so, do you see that being a part of your world going forward? Yeah, I've been acting a little bit now and producing.
票都卖光了，但它们全是机器人。就像，你知道吗？所以这是一个非常令人愉快的惊喜。所以在这部电影上，是，是吗？这仅仅是为了音乐电影，为了增强音乐事业和所有这些东西吗？还是那里也有点表演的好奇心？如果是这样，你认为这会成为你未来世界的一部分吗？是啊，我现在一直在演戏，也在做制片。
You're liking it? Honestly, I love it. I mean, I feel like I – it was funny. like once my album Brat did well, there was obviously this opportunity for me to just make another album exactly like that and like kind of gain, like capitalize on it. Sure. And for me, I've always had this sort of motto of like, what would Chloe Seven you do? And I feel like what she would have done would just be like, like, no, baby, I'm doing that.
你喜欢它吗？老实说，我爱它。我的意思是，我觉得我——这很有趣。一旦我的专辑《Brat》表现良好，显然我有一个机会去制作另一张完全一样的专辑，并从中获利。当然。对我来说，我一直有这种座右铭，比如，克洛伊·塞维尼会怎么做？我觉得她会做的就是，比如，不，宝贝，我正在做那个。
That's a great title to your new album. What would Chloe Seven you do? Well, it's like she's the coolest. And it's like, I think she would just probably. be like, no, I quit music, you know? So I was kind of like, okay, I think I would like to sort of do some kind of a drastic pivot where I, yeah, I kind of explore acting. I mean, I'm watching films like all the time, like more than I've ever listened to.
那是你新专辑的一个很棒的标题。克洛伊·塞维尼会怎么做？嗯，就像她是这里最酷的。而且，我觉得她可能只是会说，不，我退出音乐圈了，你知道吗？所以我当时想，好吧，我想我愿意做某种剧烈的转变，我，是啊，我探索一下表演。我的意思是，我一直在看电影，比我听音乐的时候多得多。
I basically never listen to music apart from like Lou Reed and like The Velvet Underground and like John Kale's solo stuff. That's like kind of it. Yeah. Right. Do you have a favorite this year? Favorite film this year that I've seen. I just watched Surat the other night.
我基本上从不听音乐，除了像卢·里德和地下丝绒，还有约翰·凯尔的个人作品。差不多就是这些。对。你今年有最喜欢的吗？今年我看过的最喜欢的电影。我前几天刚看了《苏拉特》。
Oh, yeah? I don't want to see that. Oh, is it good? I want to see that too. It was really, really, really, really amazing. Really amazing. I also love this film, Atropia, which is this film by Haley Gates, who is in, and Callum Turner is in it.
哦，是吗？我不想看那个。哦，它好吗？我也想看那个。它真的，真的，真的，真的太棒了。真的太棒了。我也喜欢这部电影，《Atropia》，这是海莉·盖茨的电影，她在里面，卡勒姆·特纳也在里面。
Oh, yeah. It's like a really, it's like very, very, like, funny, like, satire on that sort of, like, fake military zone that they have. That sounds great. It's great. It's really great. But, yeah, so I'm kind of like really enjoying watching. So I kind of started asking like a few of my friends who are either like directors or writers.
哦，是吗？这就像一个非常，非常，像，有趣的，像，讽刺，关于他们拥有的那种虚假军事区。听起来不错。它很棒。它真的很好。但，是啊，所以我真的很喜欢看。所以我开始问我的一些朋友，他们要么是导演要么是编剧。
Like do you think I could kind of do this? And they were like, yeah, but like don't be embarrassing about it. Like you don't want to be like the girl who's like, I'm an actress now. So I was like, yeah, no. No, no. I bet you'd be great. You have a great presence. I agree.
比如你觉得我能做这个吗？他们说，是啊，但别表现得尴尬。你不想成为那种说，我现在是女演员的女孩。所以我说，是啊，不。不，不。我敢打赌你会很棒。你很有风度。我同意。
I think your approach artistically the way that you look at stuff, I think, is really appropriate for it. Well, thanks. Yeah, I mean, I was interested in just doing, like, small things. Yeah, smart. So I was really lucky to kind of... I did, like, this Gregoraki movie
我认为你从艺术角度看待事物的方式，我认为，非常适合它。嗯，谢谢。是啊，我的意思是，我只对做一些小事情感兴趣。是啊，聪明。所以我真的很幸运，能够……我做了，比如，这部格雷戈拉基电影，
that I'm, like, super excited about. I'm really excited to work with Takashi Miquet this year on this film that I'm going to produce, which is, like, crazy to me to, like, go to Japan and shoot with, like, a horror altar. I'm like, this is insane. So, yeah, I'm really enjoying it. I'm really enjoying it.
我超级兴奋。我真的很兴奋今年能和高桥美纪合作这部我将要制作的电影，这对我来说太疯狂了，去日本和一位恐怖片大师拍摄。我心想，这太疯狂了。所以，是啊，我真的很享受它。我真的很享受它。
Total, like, crazy segue to nothing. But I just wanted to mention this. I thought it was so wild that you had an angel phone. Is that true, where fans could call a number and you would actually answer and pick up at any time of the day? No way. Is that true? Yeah, you know, it didn't last long because it was a nightmare.
完全，像，疯狂的过渡到虚无。但我只是想提一下这个。我觉得你有一个天使电话太疯狂了。那是真的吗，粉丝可以拨打一个号码，你真的会接听，在一天中的任何时间？不会吧。那是真的吗？是啊，你知道，它没持续多久，因为它是一场噩梦。
I'm sure. Like five minutes in. Yeah, yeah. It was good for, like, a good, solid, you know, like five hours, but it was stacked. slammed, slam, slam. But you guys should do one of them, you know, one day for an hour.
我敢肯定。就像五分钟后。是啊，是啊。它持续了，像，一个好的，扎实的，你知道，像五个小时，但它被塞满了。被轰炸了，轰炸了，轰炸了。但你们应该有一天也做一个，你知道，有一天做一个小时。
Yeah, it would be fine. We'd be sitting by the phone. It would not read. It would be so embarrassing. Then it would be one call with a bunch of notes. You guys here. This is what you need to fix. And the last thing I read that's really interesting.
是啊，那会很好。我们会坐在电话旁。它不会读。那会太尴尬了。然后会有一个带着一堆笔记的电话。你们在这里。这是你们需要修复的地方。还有我读到的最后一件事，真的很有趣。
That's a little like me, but you have 14 alarm times saved on your phone, but none of them are on. I've got that. Yeah. I'm never really. putting them on. So is it like...
那有点像我，但你的手机里存了14个闹钟时间，但它们都没开。我有那个。是啊。我从来没有真正。把它们打开。所以它是……
What do you mean? You don't believe in alarms? What's the deal? No, it's not sort of a political stance. It's more just like... I generally like I do kind of wake up roughly at the same time
你是什么意思？你不相信闹钟？怎么回事？不，这不是某种政治立场。它更多只是像……我通常，我确实大概在同一时间醒来，
unless I've been partying and then I might put an alarm on, you know? Right, right, right, right. What's the time? What's the time you generally wake up? It really depends if I've been traveling on... I'm a bit jet lagged at the moment, so I'm waking up at seven,
除非我一直在聚会，然后我可能会设一个闹钟，你知道吗？对，对，对，对。是什么时间？你通常几点醒来？这真的取决于我是否一直在旅行……我目前有点时差，所以我七点醒来，
which is very early for me. That's early. Normally I'm like a 9.30 kind of girl. So you're going to bed at 2 or 3 in the morning? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I remember that.
这对我很早。那很早。通常我是那种9点半起床的女孩。所以你凌晨2点或3点才睡觉？是啊。是啊。是啊。我记得那个。
Yeah, you should. Yeah, me too. Hey, what about travel? How do you like that part of the business? Because it is a necessary component to music, right? Yeah, you must be on the road all the time. Yeah. You have to tour, right?
是啊，你应该记得。是啊，我也是。嘿，旅行怎么样？你喜欢商业的那一部分吗？因为它是音乐的一个必要组成部分，对吧？是啊，你一定一直在路上。是啊。你必须巡演，对吧？
You can't just sell albums. No. I hate touring. I hate touring. and I really do it in quite a specific way where I think compared to a lot of my peers, I'm not really doing that much touring. My husband's in a band and they tour so much.
你不能只卖专辑。不。我讨厌巡演。我讨厌巡演。而且我确实以一种非常具体的方式去做，我觉得与我的许多同行相比，我并没有做太多的巡演。我丈夫在一个乐队里，他们巡演得太多了。
Like all the time, I think their last album they toured for like two years or something like that, which is like just not an option for me. But you'll go with them, yeah, for a bit. Sometimes you kind of pop in every once in a while. I'll pop in. I'll pop in on like the coastal cities, you know? But I'm, yeah, I'm not like, I'm not like on the bus, which is like, no way.
就像一直，我想他们上一张专辑巡演了大概两年左右，这对我来说根本不是一个选择。但你会和他们一起去，是啊，去一会儿。有时你偶尔会露面。我会露面。我会偶尔在沿海城市露面，你知道吗？但我，是啊，我不是那种，我不是那种在巴士上的人，那是不可能的。
And what about him? For my sister, for Jason and my sister, George Daniel is the 1975. That's the band. Oh, wow. Roger, Roger, okay. And then he will reciprocate and he'll come see you every once in a while when you're doing some touring. Yes, exactly. But he, it's kind of, I think, a bit harder for him because he's sort of like a six-foot,
那他呢？对于我姐姐，对于杰森和我姐姐，乔治·丹尼尔是1975乐队的。那是那个乐队。哦，哇。罗杰，罗杰，好的。然后他会回报，当你巡演时，他偶尔会来看你。是的，完全正确。但他，我觉得，对他来说有点难，因为他大概是一个六英尺，
for bald man and my fans are all a lot shorter than that and so it's very like easy for him to be like spotted when he's sort of bopping around so yeah but it's sweet we do yeah we we swap we go back and forth
光头男人，而我的粉丝都比那个矮得多，所以他当他在周围蹦蹦跳跳时，很容易被发现，所以是啊，但很甜蜜，我们确实，是啊，我们交换，我们来回。
who are the musicians that you listen to when you're growing up that you like what was the pop music pop music or any kind of music who are the bands that inspired you I was pretty diverse. I mean, I think when I was a lot younger, I was very into, like, Britney and the Spice Girls. That was definitely my bread and butter.
你成长过程中听的音乐家是谁，你喜欢什么，流行音乐或任何种类的音乐，哪些乐队激励了你？我相当多元。我的意思是，我想当我小得多的时候，我非常喜欢，比如，布兰妮和辣妹组合。那绝对是我的主食。
And then as I got a bit older, I was really into The Cure to Kate Bush, to Suis and the Baran Shees, like that kind of a world. And then I got very into, like, French electro kind of stuff, like Darth punk and justice and, like, that kind of world. So sort of all over the shop, really. And I have a question about touring because these people are...
然后当我大一点的时候，我非常喜欢治疗乐队，凯特·布什，苏西与女妖，像那种世界。然后我变得非常喜欢，比如，法国电子那种东西，像蠢朋克和正义乐队，像那种世界。所以真的到处都是。我有一个关于巡演的问题，因为这些人是……
I like French music too. Same. You do? What do you listen to your French? I listen to like La Fam. I love that band La Fam. I think that they're really cool. Charlie, what's the big...
我也喜欢法国音乐。一样。你喜欢吗？你听什么法国音乐？我听像La Fam。我喜欢那个乐队La Fam。我觉得他们真的很酷。查莉，大的是什么……
Okay, here, we're done with that. Thank you, sorry. Yeah. No, keep going. Give more bad. Sorry, man. I didn't know I was boring you. She didn't want to hear about La Farm anymore.
好的，这里，我们结束了。谢谢，抱歉。是啊。不，继续。给更多坏的。抱歉，伙计。我不知道我让你感到无聊了。她不想再听关于La Farm的事了。
I was ready to go there, actually. But no, we'll... No, go. Are there a lot of animals sounds? We have a great song called Tatiana. It's an amazing song by LaFarme. It's just an absolute bangor. Oh, yeah?
我其实准备好去那里了。但没有，我们……不，去吧。有很多动物声音吗？我们有一首很棒的歌叫《Tatiana》。那是LaFarme的一首很棒的歌。它绝对是一首劲歌。哦，是吗？
No, tell us more about that. Charlie, before you go, I want to know when you were touring, the biggest, when you were touring, the biggest on-stage flub or concert blooper or whatever that you just will never forget, like something that just went totally wrong. He loves the stage stories. I love my stage stories.
不，告诉我们更多关于那个的事。查莉，在你走之前，我想知道当你巡演时，最大的，当你巡演时，舞台上最大的失误或演唱会闹剧，或者无论什么，你永远不会忘记的，就像完全搞砸的事情。他喜欢舞台故事。我喜欢我的舞台故事。
Oh, my gosh. Like a fan that did something or a song that you screwed up or somebody. I mean, I can't, I don't know. I'm not sure I've had any really. really disastrous, like, on stage moments where I've really, like, fall. I mean, I've definitely fallen, but not in a way that I've found embarrassing or anything like that. But I do, I used to get a lot of strange gifts from fans.
哦，天哪。就像粉丝做了什么，或者你搞砸了一首歌，或者某人。我的意思是，我不能，我不知道。我不确定我有什么真正灾难性的，像，舞台时刻，我真的，像，摔倒。我的意思是，我绝对摔倒过，但不是那种我觉得尴尬的方式。但我确实，我过去常从粉丝那里收到很多奇怪的礼物。
And I think those will always stick with me. My two favorites were I got a douche, which I was asked to sign. You're welcome. And then I also received a jar of somebody's mother's ashes as a necklace. Oh. Wow. And I did exactly that well. I went, oh, didn't really, I wanted to be grateful and not offensive, but also was terrified.
我想这些会一直留在我的记忆里。我最喜欢的两件礼物是：有人送了我一个冲洗器，还让我签名。不客气。还有一次，我收到了一罐某人的母亲的骨灰，被做成了项链。噢。哇。我当时确实表现得很好。我说，噢，我真的不想表现得不礼貌，我想表达感激，但同时也感到非常害怕。
So it was, you know, so those memories will always stick me. What about dancing and singing at the same time? I always marvel at how you guys don't run out of breath, because you have to have a lot of breath to sing well. Yeah, you've got to keep moving. Not even just dancing, just moving around. Yeah, I mean, okay, so Jason, like one thing about me is I don't really like dance. You'll go away and do a deep dive and you'll... I'm going to do a deep dive and then I'm going to call you back and say,
所以，你知道，这些记忆会一直伴随着我。那一边跳舞一边唱歌呢？我总是很惊叹你们怎么能不喘不过气来，因为唱歌需要大量的气息。是的，你必须不停地动。不仅仅是跳舞，就是四处走动。是的，我是说，好吧，Jason，关于我的一点是，我其实不太会跳舞。你会去深入研究，然后你会……我会深入研究，然后我会回电给你说，
God damn, can we do this over? But see, this is what's so great about these things. You know, we get to become smarter. We're smart less people. Exactly, exactly, exactly. No, my dancing is very, it's sort of like a lot of like, flailing and it's very kind of, it's not very coordinated.
该死，我们能重来一次吗？但你看，这就是这些事情的伟大之处。你知道，我们变得更聪明了。我们是SmartLess的人。没错，没错，没错。不，我的舞蹈非常，它有点像是一堆乱挥，非常，不太协调。
You're the Tom York of, uh, yeah. I mean, not far off. It's very kind of like, like that, it's possession and vibes. I don't worry, I love it. I'm, I'm, it's less, I'm not as like poised as most. So I get the benefit of being able to sort of just, yeah, I don't have to like hit marks and do
你是Tom York式的，呃，是的。我是说，相差不远。它非常像，就像那样，是附体和氛围。我不用担心，我喜欢它。我，我，它没那么，我没有大多数人那么从容。所以我得到了好处，能够只是，是的，我不必像那样去踩点和做
choreo. I'm more just sort of flailing around. So it's a little easier for me. Yeah, yeah. Okay. Yeah. Well, listen, Charlie X-E-X, which now that I know where the name comes from, it makes me love you more.
编舞。我更多是四处乱挥。所以对我来说稍微容易一点。是啊，是啊。好吧。是啊。好吧，听着，Charli XCX，现在我知道这个名字的由来了，这让我更喜欢你了。
Will, I'll clue you in later. Yeah, clue me in. I don't care. I love it. I want to say that. Nice. No, and I want to say, I'm so, I'm such an even bigger fan. Yeah.
Will，我稍后会告诉你的。好的，告诉我吧。我不在乎。我喜欢它。我想说那个。不错。不，我想说，我，我是一个更大的粉丝。是的。
You're so cool. Oh, thanks. I listen to your music when I go on walks all the time. I love it. I'm going to listen to it even more now with just like more depth to just knowing a little bit more about you. I just think that you're awesome.
你太酷了。噢，谢谢。我散步时经常听你的歌。我喜欢它。我现在听的时候会更有深度，因为对你了解多了一点。我觉得你太棒了。
Awesome, yeah. You were awesome. Thank you so much. Thanks. And just for, am I getting this right? The moment is, it's out now by the time this episode comes out. It's out now. Maybe.
太棒了，是的。你太棒了。非常感谢。谢谢。顺便问一下，我没理解错吧？那个时刻，这集播出时它已经发布了。现在已经发布了。也许吧。
I'm sure. Well, it was released January 30th. Yeah, this is a mockumentary. Okay. Absolutely adore you. I think you're the coolest chick ever. I want to be you for Halloween. Oh, thanks, guys.
我确定。嗯，它是1月30日发行的。是的，这是一部伪纪录片。好的。绝对崇拜你。我觉得你是最酷的女孩。万圣节我想扮成你。噢，谢谢你们。
Thank you for doing this. I look forward to seeing that. Yeah. Okay. Thank you very much. Bye. Hi, hi. Bye, everybody.
谢谢你做这些。我很期待看到那个。好的。好的。非常感谢。再见。嗨，嗨。再见，大家。
Bye, bye, bye, bye, bye. What a nice person. Wow, she is. Something else. Yeah. You missed a real good first half. I know. I'm so...
再见，再见，再见，再见，再见。多好的人啊。哇，她真是。与众不同。是的。你错过了一个非常精彩的上半场。我知道。我太……
You got to listen to this episode, Willie. I can't wait. No. This is... You're on it. You're in the episode. I've had one of those. This is the episode where they go, where they go,
你得听听这一集，Willie。我等不及了。不。这是……你在里面。你在这一集里。我经历过那种情况。这一集是他们说，他们说，
you know what? It's better without them. Yeah, no, I told you. I know. You did. It's like, it's just... She is... Talk about it.
你知道吗？没有他们会更好。是的，不，我告诉过你。我知道。你告诉过我。这就像，这只是……她是……谈谈她吧。
Talk about an impressive artist and person and just right. And just like, yeah, she's one of those... Like, what is that? How do you describe that? She's just... She's got it. It's really cool. It's probably not her first lap.
谈谈一位令人印象深刻的艺术家和人，就是这样。就像，是的，她是那种……那是什么？你怎么形容那种感觉？她就是……她有那种特质。真的很酷。这可能不是她第一次来到这个世界。
No, but, you know, if you believe in that sort of old soul thing, you know, like some people have been around a few times. Yes, and exactly. And, you know, and it's not just, she's not polished. She's so real and authentic to who she is. Yeah, it's amazing. No filter. This is unapologetic.
不，但是，你知道，如果你相信那种老灵魂的说法，你知道，有些人已经来过几次了。是的，没错。而且，你知道，她不仅仅是经过打磨。她对自己非常真实和纯粹。是的，太棒了。没有滤镜。这是毫无歉意的。
I love her. I know. When we were talking before, Willie, about songs that I love for her albums, especially off of Brat. Here we go. Listen to all the hits. Sure. We list it.
我爱她。我知道。当我们之前在谈论，Willie，关于我喜欢她专辑里的歌时，特别是《Brat》里的。开始了。听听所有的热门歌曲。当然。我们列出来。
I just want you to go down the left. Did anything pop out to you? Yeah. Well, Von Dutch Talk Talk, Talk, you know, Apple was huge. Like all those songs. But your favorite would be. And Brad, of course. But my favorite was on the deluxe version that I was on Jason about.
我只是想让你顺着列表往下看。有什么让你印象深刻的吗？是的。嗯，《Von Dutch》、《Talk Talk》、《Talk》，你知道，《Apple》很火。就像所有那些歌。但你最喜欢的会是。当然还有《Brat》。但我最喜欢的是豪华版里的那首，我一直在问Jason的那首。
It's called Hello. Good. Goodbye. Bye. Everybody. All right. X, X, X, X, X, X, X, X, X, X, X, X, X, X, X, X, X, X, X, X, Smartless. Smartless is 100% organic.
它叫《Hello goodbye》。再见。大家。好的。X, X, X, X, X, X, X, X, X, X, X, X, X, X, X, X, X, X, X, X, SmartLess。SmartLess是100%有机的。
and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarf. Smart. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
由Bennett Barbico、Michael Grant Terry和Rob Armjarf手工制作。Smart。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。